President Biden's being slammed for an
out of touch comment when pressed on the
Nashville School Shooter's potential
motive police say the suspect targeted
the Christian School and the massacre
was closely planned the president claims
to be consoler in Chief but literally
laughed off that this could have been an
anti-religious attack listen
ing
I have no idea
Republican senator Josh Hawley blasting
Biden before calling on the feds to
investigate the shooting as a hate crime
that is totally beneath the Dignity of
the office of the presidency in the
United States this is a guy this is an
office that has the responsibility of
leading this country children are dead
this is a terrible terrible tragedy
Biden should be acknowledging the
targeting of people of Faith he should
be saluting the law enforcement officers
who put their lives on the line and
saved hundreds of kids but he should be
saying we're going to get to the bottom
of this we're going to call it for what
it is a hate crime and we're going to do
a full investigation make sure it
doesn't happen again and it doesn't end
there the press secretary for Arizona
Democratic governor Katie Hobbs forced
to resign this afternoon after appearing
to encourage gun violence against
transphobes on Twitter judge a part of
this show is that when we do a subject
like a school shooting you know we don't
laugh we don't joke around we treat it
with respect no you'd think the
president of the United States could
understand decorum you know at a time
when our country is literally in pain
with one of the most senseless tragic
shooting the shooting of children in
school the president comes down and
starts joking about ice cream he starts
joking about the fact that he's really
got some upstairs and Joe Biden is his
wife and then at a time when he can
console the country as you referenced he
should do something to console us and
when he was asked about the issue of
this being a hate crime look I don't
know if it is or isn't yet because I
haven't seen the manifesto but I'll tell
you what I mentioned this I know the
first day the second day I said we've
got to look into the issue because you
can rest assured if this happened at a
synagogue or it happened at a mosque
there would be people asking that
question and the president would be
saying well we're going to look into
that but we live in a day and age
unfortunately when the the degrading of
religion in our society especially
Christian religion ironically on a day
when Merrick Garland is before a
congressional committee City being asked
about whether or not you know they were
properly Prosecuting protesters in the
Dobbs decision and the protection of
Supreme Court Justices on the issue of
abortion you know all of this comes
together these are not isolated
incidents they really are a reflection
of what's going on in the country and
this president he's a blabbering he's
just blabbering all the time and he
could have said you know what it's time
for us to recognize forget about the the
hate crime issue we've got red flag laws
if something doesn't make sense find out
about it ask questions make a phone call
there is a federal red flag law Most
states have a red flag law we can
prevent this but no he's just joking
about it if Josh hawley's in favor I
don't like it I mean stop pivoting to
politics it's obvious what you are I
think we do have some of that sound you
mentioned of him was it referencing ice
cream earlier on the day of this tragedy
event let's play that
my name is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
and I Jenny's ice cream chocolate chip
I came down because you heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
full upstairs you think I'm kidding I'm
not hey so Jessica he has to know about
the shooting at that point because he
addressed it a couple of seconds later
right after so what's going on
I don't know I I think it was a very bad
thing to do I think his message on the
shooting was strong he did address how
tragic it was he talked about what he
would like to see done he's been very
consistent that he wants the assault
weapons ban brought back
um it's not in line with the consoler in
Chief
for sure but I I don't think and
obviously at the table I have a
different view of this President than a
few others Jillian with standing who's
neutral on the issue but um
I don't think he should have made it a
joke out of any of these those were
incredibly somber moments and obviously
it should be investigated as a hate
crime whether it turns out to be one or
not you have to consider it just like
where anyone where a certain group is
known to be and you're going there and
potentially targeting them we said the
same thing after Tree of Life obviously
I went back to look at the coverage of
the horrific shooting in South Carolina
the Emanuel AME Church where Dylan roof
killed nine black parishioners while
they were in Bible study in the basement
there I didn't see the same outrage on
the anti-christian issue and that from
the Republicans it was obviously an
attack on Blake on black people which he
made clear but
it should have been investigated the
same way as an attack on Christians
because it was at a house of worship and
I hope that they move forward with that
Josh Hawley though is so sanctimonious
and he is so desperate to get his cable
news hits and he did get it off of it
and he got to go on and prophely ties
about this
I think that people need to take a step
back from it and if you want to say the
president shouldn't have had this
reaction you know I can't possibly agree
with Josh Hawley about it so it can't be
that
that's obviously a bad signal to send
um but both sides do this where they put
in the punches like remember when Kamala
said I'm not going to get the vaccine
because it was like a trump vaccine if
it's from the scientists I'll do that it
just sends out a bad message about where
our government officials are
um and I don't like it I don't know if
he's thirsty for air time he just says
it should be investigated as a hate
crime that's all he said he said beneath
the Dignity of the office okay there you
go does he request to get on your show
every day I don't do the bookings okay
do you think it's an age factor I mean
you know you get a certain age and
you're like I don't care I don't you
know you just kind of is that what it is
or is he just emotionally detached
I feel I don't know
um I can't say but I I can tell you that
I think the joke was problematic on a
couple couple levels
on like a tactical level it was
unfortunate because he was making a joke
in the aftermath of a tragedy which is
never okay but at the Strategic level it
was interesting because he kind of
admitted that he's sometimes making
these decisions about things not based
on principle but instead in accordance
with the political battle lines it was
sort of like he said that out loud out
loud uh without meaning to and it's
interesting because that undercuts him
his own big initiative it was just last
week right the whole Grand gesture with
the veto threat for the DC crime bill
you know he was standing against his
party he was saying look I think this is
the wrong thing to do so I'm going to
veto this bill and now he says well
whatever Josh hawley's position is I'm
gonna stand on the opposite side it just
it it was dissonant on a whole bunch of
levels I don't understand it enough to
unpack it Greg's made some jokes I
believe you should joke after a tragedy
it's one of the most important ways to
deal with tragedies I wouldn't do it on
television but you know um I think this
story adds another kind of a stupid
layer of media click bait it's kind kind
of unnecessary you know we talk about
politicizing these things this is kind
of a politicized idea like oh you know
we're going after him for a joke in
which he's making a joke about the
person right this is exactly what
happened with was it about three or four
weeks ago yeah with the mother who's two
sons
you know and I'm always you know you
know me I'm always about less coverage
the better uh in this story so I would
rather focus on like something like the
body cam footage which if you're gonna
do exposure of a story like this that's
reality you cannot argue with that right
you can't argue with what is on body cam
footage you can art we can argue the
nuances of of of Joe what Joe Biden says
and I think you're right I think it has
to do with seeing everything and not
really caring at this point but beyond
that the best thing to come out of this
horrible event was seeing the response
of the police officers and and
and when I talk about how wrong it is to
enlarge the spectacle of of uh these
events because what it does it prays
into the infamy for future shootings we
know the repetition of material creates
Behavior I myself own 100 my pillows you
know so if we're gonna if we're gonna
enlarge the media
so much coverage yeah exactly it
encourages yes yeah yeah there's enough
research for that uh out there so if
we're going to enlarge the media
spectacle uh why not do it for amazing
police work instead of a sick killer who
wanted the spotlight who said that they
she wanted she wanted the spotlight I
would prefer to make great cops more
great cops and less or fewer pathetic
Mad Men so if we're gonna if we I don't
think we need stories like these we
could have done an a block
we could have done an a block on how the
police are not getting their due we
could have done a a block on that
footage and not this silliness and you
can watch Cops on Fox Nation that you
know what the way you twisted that into
a tease is amazing thank you that's why
you have seven o'clock I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now